[Music]
this week on
forward inequality is much more than an
economic and convenience for the people
who who aren't well treated it shreds
the reciprocity Norms that make social
cohesion and democracy possible and
that's why our politics is so screwed up
today is that they have been exploited
in a in a in a in a really pretty
terrible way for the last 30 or 40 years
and many many many of them have lost
faith in democracy and government for
reasonable reasons if you think you've
been screwed you have probably right you
are correct and if you're angry at
government for letting that happen you
have an absolute right to feel that
[Music]
way
it is my pleasure to welcome back to the
podcast the people's billionaire man
behind the $15 minimum wage and lots of
people lots of lots of parts of the
country and co-author of the new book
corporate [__] exposing the lies and
Hal truths that protect profit power and
wealth in America if anyone would know
it's Nick hanau welcome back Nick thank
you Andrew for that kind and
embarrassing introduction appreciate it
how are you dude you deserve the mantle
I I I still vividly remember reading the
article like the pitchforks are coming
for us um and being like wow this this
guy is really uh with it he he really
gets it um you've also been quoted as
saying look um How many pairs of pants
can I
buy like like saying that I'm a
billionaire I'm gonna somehow like
create all this uh these jobs it's like
well you know that's not quite how it
works it's not not not like I'm going
true corn of the market and trousers and
create all these jobs so congrats uh on
the The Amazing progress you made let's
talk a little bit about the fight for 15
because I think that's in many ways a
super relevant story for the book uh and
will help people get to know uh what
drives you yeah for sure when we cooked
up the idea for the $15 minimum wage in
200 111
12 you you know it's not that long ago
but it's important to
remember that people thought we had lost
our minds when we proposed
that and in
particular uh
people who are who who who claim to be
experts in
economics um and uh we heard from all
quarters when we decided that we should
try to do that that uh it would kill
jobs
and and when we debuted this idea and
when I started to write about it the
newspapers and magazines filled up with
criticisms of this idea claiming that if
you know if we did it it would harm the
very people we intended to help and kill
jobs and so on and so forth you you may
you may recall some of that and in the
meantime we certainly I was very
confident that that was not true because
I looked at all the empirical evidence
and there's no evidence that when you
raise wages for workers you have fewer
jobs and the longer we tried to do this
and the more we showed people that there
was no evidence for this the the less uh
they appeared to care and and what was
super interesting to me in the beginning
of this whole process Andrew was you
know you could slide any kind of study
across the table to our opponents about
how it wasn't true that when you raised
wages it killed jobs and it would not in
any way you didn't convince a single one
no no not one of them stopped saying if
you raise wages it killed jobs and it
took a little while
for me I mean being I suppose naive and
little dance to realize that they
weren't saying those things because they
were true they were saying raising wages
kills jobs because it was the most
effective thing they'd ever found to
keep wages low and profits high in other
words the The Narrative had nothing to
do with truth it was just super
effective in defending the status quo
and maintaining an economic Arrangement
that benefited people at the top and
didn't benefit anybody else and I wrote
a long piece about this many years ago
now called the threat not a theory where
I explored sort of uh you know in many
ways to explain other people but also to
explain to myself why these narratives
are so important that that and it just
became clear and clear that that phrase
raising wages kills jobs sounds like a
claim on economic cause and effect what
it really is is an intimidation tactic
masquerading as
economics uh you know it's basically the
oldest trick in the capitalists Playbook
you ask for raise I threaten to fire you
works like a charm and as since the
beginning of capitalism
and uh but we fought through that and
but that was a big that was a super big
lesson for me and in in the interim I
bumped into this guy another another uh
a guy who had spent his career working
on these sort of economic issues who who
had been so frustrated by this kind of
thing that he spent he took a he took a
sabatical and um created a database of
thousands of quotes in history like this
our co- my co-author Donald Cohen
because what what he showed and what
what became clearer and clearer as you
looked at this stuff that in any domain
where there is concentrated power and
wealth any effort to address an issue
will encounter this kind of narrative
this push back and the push back always
takes the same form and this is the
point of the book this corporate
[__] book is that it's always
pro-social language I'm on your side but
uh what you're going to do is actually
going to hurt the people you're trying
to help yes exactly no I I you know I'm
I'm totally in agreement with you but
you know why would you that's not
practical to raise the minimum wage that
would hurt them because then we'd have
to fire them right it's not practical to
address climate change because then we'd
all be poor it's not practical to give
women the right to vote because then the
the poor things wouldn't be able to you
know lead their lovely lives it's not
practical to let the slaves uh go free
because we treat them better than they
would be treat you know like it just
goes on and on and on and on and on and
on and on and so I had this um you know
it's really frustrated by this and um
I've said before I I have a friend who
does um psychological research she's a
she's a one of the world's leading
neuroscientists and um researchers her
name is Molly Crockett and I called her
up about this because I was really
fascinated by this phenomenon and she's
like oh Nick this is so so so simple why
this is always the case and that is
because the most important element of
human moral reasoning is intention what
you intend to do is how people judge you
which is why if you uh if you
deliberately murder somebody you go to
jail or worse but if you're driving your
car down the freeway and somebody Hucks
themselves off an overpass and hits your
car you're not going to you're you're
you're clearly not liable for that right
right you you will not be charged with a
crime even though the people to be clear
are both dead they're equally dead um
and that structure that way of um using
narrative to to to to um deflect change
is at the core of how powerful interests
protect their protect uh those interests
and so we uh Don had this fantastic
database of these things and he yeah the
quotes are really jarring and funny I
mean every point in American history
yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean go back a
couple hundred years right and and yeah
and he sort of gifted this to us and we
we sat on it for a couple years because
we didn't really know what to do with it
we thought it was really important and
then we had this idea we got to turn
this into a coffee table book right we
got to get this out to people because
the thing is that's right there it is
all this Glory from all all throughout
American history where you're like oh
wow and you do see a pattern yeah no no
no no and the thing is is that the thing
that's so important to realize is that
every time somebody makes one of these
claims new in in in a new way it's
always plausible like it's
plausible that social media isn't
harming young girls I know and we I
definitely want us to talk about social
media because I think that is the
Contemporary version but quick question
so you're sitting across a table
someone's like hey raise a can destroy
jobs and like well here are studies that
say don't and then the person is
unpersuaded unconvinced is it just uh
like obstinacy is it that they're
actually uh compensated by an interest
group that wants um to protect the
status quo is it just I don't care what
uh the reality is like I'm I'm like a
tribalist you know you I think I think
to be fair to people it's a little of
all those things and it depends on who
you're talking to um
so just to be clear with respect to the
for example for with respect to the $15
minimum wage or the minimum wage more
generally there were a huge number of
well-meaning
folks on the left who believed that the
that raising the minimum wage of $15 an
hour was a was an would be an economic
catastrophe and that's because those
people went to college and took econ 101
courses and if you take an econ 101
course today you're going to learn that
there's an inverse relationship between
you know uh between the the amount that
you pay somebody and how how many jobs
there are even though that's not true
because that's a sort of a primitive way
of understanding economics that they
teach people and so even Democratic
senators who theoretically should be on
the right side of an issue like this
were like no no no this is crazy crazy
crazy and so there are for sure there at
least three camps there are the people
who were genu who are often genuinely
confused about the
issues there are people whose interests
are so aligned with keeping things the
same that they simply cannot bring
themselves to believe that it would
would be true that for example raising
wages didn't kill jobs right like so you
have to I think this is a really
interesting thing about human psychology
is that everybody has to be the hero of
Their Own Story right everyone wants to
feel like they're being moral and so if
you run a big exploitive Service
Company what you desperately want to
believe is that paying people
$725 an hour or
$213 plus tips is righteous and moral
and is the right thing to do and when
somebody comes along and says no that's
a terrible thing to do to people that
you should pay them much much more those
folks generally will desperately seek to
find a reason why your claim is not true
and nothing is more convenient than the
idea that well we could help help those
people but that would actually harm them
more than help them and so and then
there and then so that's the second
category of people who simply just can't
bring themselves to F that the you know
the cognitive dissonance is too much for
them and then they're the and then
they're the straight mercenaries who
don't give a [__] right they're just
like I don't care whether K kills jobs
or it doesn't I am paid to keep
corporate profits high and executive
bonuses high and I'm just going to say
whatever I have to say to to to protect
those interests good old category three
yeah yeah yeah yeah good old category
and but I honestly think that the the
the the PE if all we had to fight
against were the people in Category 3
Andrew I think we' we we we'd make much
more progress faster the The Mercenaries
actually are are few and far between I
think it's the people who are confused
and the TR and the true believers who
are the who are the real obstacles to to
to to to change uh the people who simply
cannot bring themselves to believe that
the way in which
Society um is organized that benefits
them so much uh is unjust right like
dude you live in New York surrounded by
guys in finance who make obscene amounts
of money doing
nothing right to be fair they they they
create zero value in the
world and but you know try that at a
dinner party in New
[Laughter]
York
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
it's a pretty short list of things you
can do that are going to make you
happier healthier more energetic more
productive every single day you know
what's on that list getting the right
freaking mattress and what's the right
mattress for you if you go to Helix
sleep you take their personalized sleep
quiz and they will send you one of 20
unique mattresses made for you and you
alone well not you and you alone like 5%
of people do the math for 100 night free
trial you can sleep on this thing for 3
months it will keep you cool don't just
take my word for it my kids seek out
this mattress in the house it's the
number one rated mattress picked by GQ
and Wired Magazine this mattress will
actually make you happier healthier and
more productive Helix is offering 20%
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com yangang this is their
best offer yet and it won't last long
with with Helix better sleep starts
[Music]
now no I literally wrote a book called
smart people should build things Nick so
you know I mean my some people generally
know where I am on this stuff yeah um I
think there's one quote that that that
speaks to the problem which is up in St
Clair's famous it's hard to convince man
of something when his understanding it
uh you know like means he doesn't have a
job
yes
yes that's it like there's a huge amount
of that and you know the other really
interesting thing is is that any any
like any fight for
Justice
Means
rearranging status Privileges and power
right like and
people the most important thing to most
wealthy people is their status their
Privileges and their power that's one of
the things that you know people who end
up at the tippy top of these things
mostly wind up there because they're
pathologically ambitious and Status
conscious yeah again man it's one reason
I like you is that uh you know you're
you're obviously um at the tippy top but
you don't make too much of it and you're
channeling your energies and efforts and
resources to try and uh do positive
things yeah I I turn out to be
pathologically ambitious too I'm just
trying to channel it in a slightly less
harmful way
it's very productive like anyone can
check out the work that you're doing so
I I I do want to run through that
there's another um uh famous quote that
your book reminded me of which is the uh
first they ignore you then they laugh at
you then they fight you and then you win
yes um so so then for you guys you have
these six counter arguments that they
brandish anytime you try and do
something and I I'm just going to read
these in order because they're GNA make
people laugh and but they're going to
feel familiar um so so number one is uh
it's not actually a problem right denial
denial denial yeah yeah number two is so
it's like yeah people are fine making
whatever the heck amount of money um
number two is the free market knows best
yes uh number three is uh it's not our
fault it's your fault or their fault
yeah number four is what we were just
talking about is it's a job killer Yes
number five is you'll only make it worse
which is tied in there it's like hey
you're going to actually hurt people
trying to help and the number six is one
I've heard an awful lot
it's socialism yes anything that that
does anything in the direction of people
or workers is socialism yeah any
anything which in any way restricts the
power of the powerful is socialism by
definition yeah yeah so anyway yeah and
those are those and you know there are
all sorts of ways that we could have
organized this but those are the sort of
the categories that leapt out at us and
well I think I like that order because
it seemed kind of sequential to me is
number one is like yeah this isn't
really a problem and then after that
doesn't
work okay it is a problem but it's your
problem and then it's like well we could
solve the problem but then you'd be then
we'd have to fire you and then you know
like it just keeps going and going and
going but I think that I think what
what's the real reason we wrote the book
um and uh we we should just say to
people who are listening to this podcast
that this is not a heavy lift
set like some of the things that uh we
exp you know people are exposed to
around political economy this is this is
a picture book right yeah I'm gonna try
pictur this is like this is something to
be looked at uh you know from time to
time and quotes from different eras
that's right it's yeah it's not a grind
to get through but what was so what
seemed so important to us is to give
people the historical cont for people
who like all the old Tunes all that kind
of stuff right you can't buy this on
Kindle by the way it just would not work
you have to actually get the physical
copy um and the thing is is that you
know in the absence of historical
context lots of these quotes seem
plausible but what what what teaches you
about the patterns is seeing the pattern
right when you realize that people have
been saying this stuff in the same way
for Generations right you're just like
oh my God like they they said that about
everything they said that about a lead
paint they said that about what is it
the the lamon labor child labor
slavery you pick the most egregious
awful practice there was a guy who was
standing up to defend that saying these
things right Toco whatever it is
whatever it was no smoking is good good
for you um it's not a problem it's not a
problem people can make their own
choices that's right it's not problem
it's your problem that's
right all of it it's just it's just it's
just and what we felt was so useful to
the for the good of the order is that by
sharing the history of these quotes with
people it effectively inoculates your
brain against them in the future so once
you seen the patterns you can't unsee
the patterns right you're just like oh
my God like you turn on the TV and you
have see one of these clowns spouting
one of these things and you're like oh
that's the same [__] that they said
about the last thing you know it's just
obviously not true uh you know one fun
thing Nick is that um so one issue you
raised in the book which I was uh happy
about uh is social media and you just
reference something saying hey you think
it's probably uh bad for girls mental
health which I totally agree with by the
way um and one of the interesting things
is that if you try and apply these
arguments to social media some of them
don't work at all like so so it's not a
problem that works like is there a
problem then free market knows best is
well like let let people figure it out
but then you think doesn't that make any
sense it's not our fault it's your fault
but then it's a job killer thing makes
zero sense because the social the social
media it's like no one like no not that
many people work at these companies um
you'll only make it worse is also hard
to like you know when you when you look
at this you think wow like social media
um really ought to be teed up nicely for
this because some some of these
counterarguments uh don't even apply
yeah but I mean they're they're
vigorously making the argument the a
that it's not a problem there there
isn't a problem or B that if there is a
problem it's on you parents to control
this right it's not our fault it's your
fault and see I it
you know the free market will fix it
here here's here's their version oh
we'll we can regulate ourselves wh why
would we do something that would harm
our users right trust us don't you don't
we don't need any stinking
regulation right you know I mean it
again it it all recycles in very very
similar ways and you know one of the
questions I've been asked um about the
book many times is where will the future
[__] come from like where do you
where will Lies come from in the future
and my answer is any place there's
concentrated power and wealth you show
me concentrated power and wealth I will
show you
[__] right like there's never not an
example uh and um you know it's just it
just it's it's a fascinating thing you
know the other thing that always like
really struck me Andrew and working
through all this stuff is like why is it
like you just got to ask this question
like why is it that the Chamber of
Commerce never says the truth about
these things which is well of course we
don't want to pay you more we want
profits to be as high as possible and
those executive bonuses and insane
salaries or how we afford yachts and
planes and everything else and we don't
give a crap about you and your family we
just want your wages to be lower like
what like this is obviously the truth it
it wouldn't be very effective I mean it
would be honest but it wouldn't be very
effective no well in all of these issues
where these stuff this stuff has been
litigated in in all of our Lives we have
never once said seen somebody stand up
and say the truth right which is like
well of course it's poisonous but it's
incredibly profitable for us to sell you
that poison sure addictive addictive
poison it's addictive poison are you
crazy of course we're going to keep
selling it to you like why would we not
like we don't give a rip like it's super
profitable we fly around in our own Jets
and have giant yachts and make lots of
money and you use this product and can't
stop and get sick well that's somebody
else's problem right it's your problem
we don't give a crap what like in the
history of capitalism no one has ever
stood up and said something like that
even though it is clearly true why
because if they did the intention would
be clear and people would be angry they
wouldn't be
afraid hey YouTube thanks for watching
please do hit like And subscribe and hit
that Bell if you want to be notified
every time a new episode drops probably
on Mondays but hit that Bell and thank
you yeah the the obfuscation uh works
pretty well you know you can just money
the water and then especially in this
information environment because people
be like ah you know you think that I
think that I've got to study you've got
to study yeah um so Nick um when did you
have the Awakening to be heading in this
direction uh you're talking about 2011
was the beginning of fight for 15 um
let's let's say for argument sake um
you've been at this for like 12 to 15
years yeah or or so and and you've had
you put up some major victories yeah uh
you you funded some awesome initiatives
you have advised the Biden
Administration on middle out economics
trying to make it so that the the econom
is more more fair um I dare say that
neither you nor I think corporate
[__] is on like the decline I mean
it's probably as high or higher than
it's ever been I feel like the
concentration of power is higher than
it's ever been well I mean those
feelings are based in fact it is true
yeah and I I I'm friendly with some of
the folks who went into um the antitrust
division yeah and they they had some in
my opinion accurate ideas as to um what
should happen but then they haven't
actually been able to uh implement or
execute meaningfully where some of the
the big tech companies have been
concerned I think that you know it
hasn't there hasn't been like the
equivalent of like uh you know baby Bell
breakup or even like what happened to
Microsoft not yet back in the day and
you know you probably were somewhere
close to the Microsoft thing since uh
yeah how how are you feeling about your
fight um because and and I'm going to
put myself in your shoes for a minute
like I started a nonprofit in 2011
Venture for America that led me to to
run for office I wrote that book smart
bu should build things back in 2011 and
then like you you know I've now written
like uh you know several books and like
and still trying to drive in a direction
um how's your oneman gang movement not
one I know you have a team around you
and some awesome people that I know but
like are you feeling good and bad or bad
like you know you like do do you think
that we're winning or losing so that's a
great question uh there's good news and
there's bad news let me start with the
bad news the bad news is that we dug
ourselves a hole over the last 50 years
that is very very deep
[Music]
um and the amount of economic inequality
and Injustice in the United States for
example that has been
created and not everything has gotten
worse right but um certainly if you look
at economic inequality oh yeah yeah it
like like productivity and and wages
diverged starting about 50 years ago
when they went like in totally different
directions that's right and so we have
built we dug a whole it's a it's a it's
a effectively a $ 55
trillion Hole uh which is which is the
aggregate amount of money that has
flowed incrementally from the bottom 90%
of Americans to the top 1% over the last
50 years so around2 and a half trillion
dollars extra that flows from the bottom
90% to the top 1% today per year and
that the problem with that hole is that
you know inequality is much more than an
econ omic inconvenience for the people
who who aren't well treated it shreds
the reciprocity Norms that make social
cohesion and democracy possible and
that's why our politics is so screwed up
today is that it is just an objective
fact that for most of the people in the
country certainly the bottom 80 or
90% they have been exploited in a in a
in a in a really pretty terrible way for
the last 30 or 40 years and many many
many of them have lost faith in
democracy and government for reasonable
reasons right like that that it's just a
fact that if you're in the if you were a
median you think you've been screwed you
have right you are correct you have been
screwed and if you're angry at
government for letting that happen you
have an absolute right to feel that way
you are correct you got totally screwed
and the government of the United States
of
America aided and abetted that for for
better or worse it is just a fact and
people are pissed and people on the left
are pissed and people on the right are
pissed and it is an open question
whether our democracy will
survive this self-inflicted wound that's
the bad news the good news is that when
I started on this journey in 200
six
seven8 which is when I first started
coming to terms with
inequality people didn't even recognize
it was a problem if you even raised it
in polite company people got angry when
I first started talking about raising
the Mi minimum wage even the people on
the left thought I had lost my mind so
Andrew here's the thing there are
9,500 professional economists in the
United States something like that when
we debuted the $15 minimum wage not one
wrote in
support not one came to our rescue not
one published a big article in the New
York Times saying this is absolutely the
right thing to do all this [__]
about them about it killing jobs is not
true it's just a scare tactic this is
the right thing to do Andrew when I when
I came up with that idea even the left
leaning economists who populate the sort
of left uh infrastructure of activists
thought we had lost our minds right okay
if you fast forward to today the
economic cons look Barack Obama was
President for eight years inequality
Rose under Barack Obama it didn't
decline why because he was surrounded by
economists who were neoliberals he was
trapped in that neoliberal Paradigm and
and and so here's the good news is that
that cons census has almost entirely
changed today that everywhere you look
people are recognizing how badly
neoliberalism has harmed the society or
Market fundamentalism trickle down
economics or whatever you want to call
it every University is standing up
efforts to rethink capitalism I mean
everywhere you go there's another
seminar or whatever it is on reimagining
the economy rethinking
capitalism you know the president of the
United States went to the picket lines
for the UAW workers right unprecedented
in American history and so the good news
is that 10 years ago even the people who
should have been fighting for uh for the
right stuff were paralyzed uh and today
they're all engaged in the fight like
look why is the Biden Administration the
most transformational Administration on
economic policy in since Roosevelt
because they're the first Administration
since Reagan to break with neoliberal
Orthodoxy right that's a clean break
they just said we don't buy this
[__] anymore we're gonna actually
improve people's lives all this nonsense
about Job killing is just it's just
nonsense just it's just a red herring
and so that's the good news is that we
are in a moment of transformation a lot
of people the the the E economic and
political consensus is rapidly changing
and there is real hope for for real
change and it may be too
late you know and it may be too late uh
which would be uh terrible and sad and
awful for you and me and a lot of other
people uh but but so that's that's my
view is it is that there's some bad news
and some good
news happy holidays you know what's
tough to do during holiday season eat
right and not gain weight and not
frankly get a little extra tummy going
because you don't have time you're on
the go the way you can make it so you
stay healthy and charged up in the right
way is to use Factor America's number
one ready to eat meal delivery service
Chef prepared dietician approved ready
to eat meals delivered straight to your
door this is the service that's going to
change your life I love their shredded
chicken taco bowl as just one example
it's not just for dinner and one thing
that's great about it is that it's
totally commitment free it's not one of
those things that's tricky you can turn
it on you can turn it off but you are
not going to want to turn it off because
it's going to change your life for the
better this December you can get factor
and enjoy eating well without the hassle
just choose your meals and enjoy fresh
flavor packed meals delivered straight
to your door ready in Just 2 minutes no
prep No Mess great for frankly the guy
who aren't going to be cooking for
themselves so well so head to factor
meals.com
sl50 and use code y50 to get 50% off
that's code y50 at factor meals.com y50
to get 50% off try Factor
[Music]
today I agree with um both of those
takes uh you know one happened one thing
that happened when I was running for
president Nick um is I'd say to folks is
like you know if you uh let things get
out of balance for 30 40 years the the
rebalancing actually is going to seem
very dramatic it is no for sure so for
sure and then my proposals to rebalance
it were you know obviously to um start
giving everyone money yeah um my
favorite thing of the last several years
in American policy was the enhanced
child tax credit that lifted millions of
kids out of poverty and then because our
political system is so limited and
dysfunctional now we put them all back
into poverty you know like 15 months
later I mean it was unconscionable um at
least on that one a bunch of economists
came out and said yeah we should totally
keep doing this but no for sure and
there there yeah and and and you know
I'm not a a Ubi Enthusiast in the way
that you are but but clearly there is a
huge amount of new empirical evidence
suggesting supporting your view that
when you just give people money it turns
out to be great for them and great for
the economy overall right I mean the the
the American Rescue plan being you know
a great example of that right dude I'm
I'm an Evidence guy just like you are
and and one of the things I you know
like I I will cop to is that when people
say hey were you for lifting the the
minimum wage and then I had to get do
this tortuous it's like well I prefer
just giving the money but if you take
that off the table then I'm totally for
raising the minimum wage
which
is which is where I've been but you know
like people obviously you know it's hard
to to have um both those thoughts in
your head I I'm with you on the depth of
the problem I'm with you on the shifting
in thinking about it because you're
right now everyone sees inequality as a
as an issue and then they're they're
happy to to try and consider addressing
it I'm heartened by the enhanced child
tax credit that the stuff that scares
the [__] out of me is that we had a long
extended period of abundance that some
folks think uh is ending um we've had
this Golden Goose in the form of the uh
dollar as the global Reserve currency uh
and then people are looking up saying
wow we like 0 33 trillion you know like
now interest rates are higher and you
know there there all these issues um I'm
still of the mind that we must try and
dig out of this hole that you described
that the the your 55 trillion is a
fascinating number for People's
reference the size of the US economy is
around 25 trillion um so so Nick's
saying that essentially like two years
of of economy has gotten transferred um
uh to to the hands of the the top one or
10 percent it's it's a Herculean
challenge for us to make use of
Institutions that people are losing
faith in literally day by day uh and
then try and reverse some of what's
happened over the last 50 years yeah no
and and it's particular particularly
hard when you have one of the political
parties which effectively is a
neist uh organization that doesn't want
government to be functioning right like
people are frustrated I know people in
the administration are super frustrated
by the disconnect between the
achievements the legislative
achievements of the Biden Administration
and how people are feeling about the
economy and um I I'm frustrated by it
but not surprised because for 95% of
Americans the economy does not exist as
an abstraction they don't read the New
York Times it is my job and the expenses
and the and the and the facts are that
we lived through this once in a hundred
year Global supply chain disruption of
the pandemic which pushed prices up
substantially and wages are rising but
but for a lot of people stuff just got a
lot more expensive and a lot harder and
and yes the IRA is going to bring
jillions of new jobs and technology and
all sorts of great things and chips and
the infrastructure plan all of that
still good but for the 95% of Americans
who already have a job right they're not
going to directly benefit or or
viscerally benefit from a lot of these
programs uh directly and if they do it's
not going to be for a couple of three
years even then and in the meantime if
you had if if if you hadn't had Kristen
cinon uh that clown from Virginia yeah
Mansion we could have raised the minimum
wage which was really helped people we
could have gone farther with overtime
you know we could have done a bunch of
things that would have affected people
right now in a substantial way and that
would have made a big difference and but
of course enhance trial tax credit among
those things 100% right exactly exactly
there were all these things that you
could have done uh obviously the Supreme
Court struck down um uh the uh student
debt reduction right uh these are all
things that would have really helped
people and I think um uh made a huge
difference on the on the deficit I think
what's important for folks to realize is
that the de you know America's deficits
are are not were not caused by propagate
spending on middle class programs they
were it was caused by first and foremost
wage suppression right so if the median
full-time worker in America today had
earned simply maintained their same
share of GDP since 70 in 1975 inste of
earning about $50,000 a year they'd earn
about $100,000 a year so if we had an
economy where the median full-time
worker earned 100 not 50 we would have
zero budget deficits zero because the
tax revenue that would be have been
created by all of that extra Revenue um
uh all of that extra income W would have
would have paid all the stuff down but
the real culprits of course were giant
tax cuts for the rich and a couple of
three incredibly stupid Wars right yeah
yeah and this one thing I like about you
too Nick is that you're very open being
like look tax me more it's cool you know
would have been fine it would have been
fine it would have been fine and and you
know taxes on taxes on rich people are
slightly higher than they were but boy
you know you think about where it was in
the early 2000 you know like cap gain
cap gain tax rates at
15% um you know like super wealthy
people earning millions or tens of
millions or hundreds of millions of
dollars year and having a having a total
tax burn I don't 12% or 15% or whatever
it is it's nuts yeah one of the most
dangerous things about uh the economy
today is that people see it through
partisan lenses yeah where if you're a
republican just feel better about the
economy when a Republicans in charge if
you're uh and by the way the Republican
partisan lens effect is stronger than
the Democratic partisan lens effect um
we which is so here's my solution by the
way this will get us out of this mess
Nick I hope you like it okay okay list
what we do is what we do is regardless
of who wins this next election we take
the loser and uh put them in a replica
of the White House and then let everyone
who supported that person just turn tune
into that channel they'll feel good
about the economy the other side will
feel good about the economy everyone
will feel good about the economy and
then just like tune in to the president
you want and uh we're we're golden I
thought you were going to say put the
loser in a terrarium full of fire ants
no and then then give him a $400,000 TV
contract a year uh you know get some get
some extras in there there you go people
can visit it it's fine there you
go there you go so that is one of the
dangers is that you would think hey if I
come through for the economy the economy
then voters will see it and I'll be
rewarded but now the economy is almost
feelings yeah yeah yeah well and people
definitely yeah there are definitely a
bunch of people in the country that are
so partisan that no fact pattern will
will change their minds none yeah right
yeah but if
10% of people who vote ordinarily vote
Republican are are um available
persuadable um that's transformational
right so there's a third of the country
that you simply are never going to
you're never going to reach it's just
impossible but there is a and there a
third of the third of the country on the
left that probably is unreachable in the
same way uh but there's a nice third in
the middle who I think are open-minded
enough to be be persuaded by facts and
to be persuaded by what they see in
evidence and and actual differences and
I think I I I think that that's why
delivering for people actually doing
things that will benefit it's the only
way out it's the only way out we have to
deliver for people because there's not
nothing else you can do there is no
alternative there is no alternative
there's no
alternative this podcast is sponsored by
expressvpn going online without
expressvpn is like changing while
leaving your window wide open gross you
might not have anything to hide but why
give random creeps a chance to invade
your privacy that's why I use expressvpn
it's super easy you hit a button and
then you just beam in best of all you
know no one can see what you're doing no
big tech companies no ad companies no
other companies why use expressvpn when
you go online it is just you and you're
surfing no one can see it you know it's
the way to go because a bunch of big
companies say hey all of you high-end
consultants and spies use
expressvpn secure your online activity
by visiting expressvpn.com
today that's ex p s vpn.com yangang and
you can get an extra 3 months free
expressvpn.com
yangang so this book is part of your
portfolio of activities this useful bit
of inoculation very positive um what
else you working on right now that we
can be excited about well we just pushed
through a an increase in the overtime
threshold uh through the Department of
Labor that is now in um it's an
executive order that is now being uh
they were there was a comment period and
now they're going to analyze it what
they should have done what the
administration should have done is
raised it to about $85,000 a year uh and
if they had done that that would have
brought the overtime threshold back up
to the former high water Mark instead uh
because they were
crybabies uh they only raised it to
about
$58,000 a year which will still benefit
millions and millions of people so
that's a thing that my team was super
involved in and I feel very strongly
about the overtime threshold is to the
middle class what the minimum wage is to
low wage work so that's a that's a
really cool thing that's happening right
now another really cool thing that's
happening right now that we were deeply
involved in is um the transformation of
how the federal government analyzes and
judges the impact of Regulation through
through uh a regulatory agency called oi
o oira and it will not surprise you to
learn that the governing um structure of
that institution was written by the same
people who told you that raising wages
killed jobs and tax cuts for the rich
cig growth basically it was a it was a
rubric
where anything that costs corporations
money was bad by definition and anything
that was good for people would be like
well very hard to calculate so we
probably shouldn't look at that and so
this new way of understanding how we
should regulate uh will be much
friendlier and constructive with respect
to the benefits it generates for the
broad population and that's another
thing that um is very very
exciting and then um and then you know
more abstractly uh I and my friend Eric
bker have been trying to finish a book
on economics for years now um we're
getting very very close but what you
know I I think that at the core of the
problem in the United States and around
the world is a profoundly broken way of
understanding economic cause and effect
that you can call neoclassical or
Orthodox or whatever you want but
understanding GDP is a adequate measure
of growth understanding change that man
yeah yeah yeah understanding um markets
as efficient they're not uh
understanding people as reliably selfish
and rational we aren't you know all of
that stuff understand the economy as an
equilibrium system that's par optimal
all of these things are plausible but
not true but more importantly they are
massively biased towards the status quo
it it that belief system makes it such
that if you enact policy on the basis of
it only one thing are founding a new
school of Economics what the hell is it
called uh it's going to be called Market
humanism dude I love Market humanism
holy crap yeah that's what we're doing
yeah so I mean obviously this is a
comically ambitious Endeavor but uh but
we think that we're basically on the
right track and that you can't really
can't really fix these problems if you
use the old constructs and structures
and ideas right you want I use the same
example I said hey you know what's going
to be great for GDP
AI like how's How's that gonna work out
for the average American worker there
you know yeah yeah well yeah you know
what's great for GDP
cancer right like it's just a ter it's a
terrible terrible way of understanding
whether we're getting you whether we're
you know improving Market humanism I
love it dude I actually
um called something similar I called it
human centered
capitalism Market humanism might be
better as a name but I'm I'm pretty sure
the ideas are close in that I said look
we should be measuring the economy by
how people are doing outcomes yes
Health outcomes not outputs absolutely
100% yeah and look you and I are on the
same page of course a and again coming
back to the good news that we talked
about earlier
there's a there's a there's an emerging
consensus around this these sets of
ideas that
people you
know people recognize that we went off
the tracks and that we got to get the
I'm mixing my metaphores now but we got
to we got to point the country in a in a
different point the world actually in a
different and better
Direction uh and you know there'll be a
lot of different ways in which we talk
about that and address that but they're
all generally headed in the right
direction which is trying to get the
economy to serve people rather than
people serving the economy which is what
centered economy man that's that's
that's that's that's what it's all about
so wow man well I can't wait to have you
back on to talk that book when do you
think you guys are
gon I mean this book is an achievement
but like no the other one's going to be
much more interesting I mean we're we're
we're we basically have a manuscript now
we're in the editing phase so what that
means it's it's on its way man because
you've done the hard work no yeah yeah
it's it's a lot of work and and and it's
it's risky that the problem is is that
the world of Economics is very very
um how is how should I put it they're
very talized yes and they're very touchy
about
criticism um what's so interesting is
that every time you talk to economists
about these
problems
like 100% of
them are like oh well we didn't we don't
believe that like all that old I don't
know who believes that that old stuff
and you're like well somebody believes
it it got put it like and the and the
and the Poetry Department didn't come up
with this cockamamy stuff you bust out
whatever the micro macro textbooks like
they are teaching this at Harvard right
like you know like I don't know like
maybe you didn't believe it but like it
is the consensus it is what you taught I
can vou for the fact that that's what
you learned so yeah you know like that
yeah good for you for not wanting to be
attached to it but like somebody is
somebody's
fault you know the chemistry Department
didn't do this physics department didn't
do this I I love it man Market humanism
is is what we need um if people want to
keep up with you your work
um how can they best do so oh golly I
would have I used to say follow me on
Twitter but that that that that that
that thing is such a hellhole today that
I I never uh I don't go very much um uh
but just check out our website Civic
Ventures um Civic ventures.com Ventures
yeah well Nick congratulations corporate
[__] exposing the lies and have
truths that protect profit power and
wealth in America uh Gods me to you and
your work and let let's try and uh build
this uh Market humanist human centered
economy together my friend I love it I
love it well Andrew thank you so much
for having me on the podcast was super
fun to talk to you as
always